hey what's going on it's Billy blue
blazer
um I'm wearing this jacket you know why
it's out of respect
I'm about to interview one of the
biggest Legends in Show Business
um I got to see this man perform live
a couple of months back he absolutely
blew me away
um
I'm about to sit down with the one and
only Mr Paul Anka
[Music]
once people find out you have cigars
yeah you get them by the truckload you
could literally start your own shop so
what I did was I bought I bought a
humidor Comedy Store for the younger
Comics or whatever yeah I just brought
them all down there so my thing is if
I'm one of those guys like if it's in
the house I'm gonna consume it right
cookies or whatever so I got to make
sure so if I have a hundred cigars in
the house I'm gonna smoke honor cigars
so I what I like I have to get back to
what a cigar is supposed to be which is
it's an event yeah you're sitting down
oh yeah with somebody you know usually
it's one of my knucklehead friends it's
not usually Paul Anka
what do you do Cohibas
what do I do you know I actually I I uh
I don't have a hookup for real Cubans
really and people just easy I is it yeah
Miami people always tell them this is a
Cuban and I light it and they're all
excited for me and as I'm tasting I'm
like this isn't [__] real oh no this
is the only way I can tell a Cuban's
real as I light it I always after one or
two Puffs I go oh my God right and the
last time I did that I was I was in Tel
Aviv Tel Aviv Tel Aviv and I was in
Jaffa right outside right outside of um
kidding me where did you work in in
Israel I worked this great place in in
uh some did you use that big out
historical outdoor place because I just
got back there I did two shows there
this summer I had a great time you know
what's fun it was funny to go there is
like not living there is you just look
around and it's like there's all these
beautiful women yeah Palestinians and
Israeli and all that and you're sitting
there going like what is the problem
right Mediterranean Sea I know I know
what the problem is but like well we
know that there's been a mess over there
for years you know it's people are
idiots it's amazing I know as an
audience you know they live life
to the fullest and I've been going there
for years even though I've been getting
calls from people you know why you're
going and all that [__] and I
finally went on television I said just
mind your own [__] business you know
because I usually stops it what people
say
no all this is like a little push bar
yeah why would you do that it's like why
do you give a [__] because I want to I'm
not telling you what to do yeah exactly
[__] off yeah and then they go oh all
right I feel like this is this is a
really like a big
um
bully time with that type of stuff and I
I kind of learned that if you just sort
of
you know look you got to be open-minded
if you are doing something and it
bothers somebody like I'm you know I
don't give a [__] oh I didn't realize
that sorry right but like if it's just
like politically motivated yeah which I
I can't I hate that I'm sick of it I'm
backing off yeah oh I haven't watched I
haven't watched the news in like
Bill and you know since before the
pandemic it's one of the greatest things
my buddy the other day was going to dude
this whole country's going to [__] this
happened this happened this happened I
finally said I was like buddy you know
what happened today a whole bunch of
great things happened today and they're
not going to show it on the news right
and now you're sitting here and you're
gonna flip out and then also the way
they presented
is when something happens it's always
like this happened they act like this is
the beginning of the story
you know especially when they're dealing
with like uh race class and all of this
type of stuff they don't go all the way
back and be like well it started with
this and because of that now we're here
yeah and they just get they just get
people like I feel like CNN Fox News
their job every day is to divide America
totally it's like they should be shut
down yeah they're being told what to do
these guys are making a shitload of
money reporting it told what to do and
it's become like a it's a circus do you
know anybody who watches CNN or Fox on a
regular basis that even remotely sounds
sane
or happy
no I don't yeah they always got their
eyebrows up they're like they're going
to do this yeah do you know what else it
is most people watching that I figured
out when you talk to them and you got to
be careful who you talk to they don't
know how to get to the source
what the issue is right they're taking
what's on the surface they don't do any
homework to get to the source of what's
real
well then they also and they also like
politicize like everything is like
you know look what the guys with the red
ties are doing look what the guys with
the blue ties are doing I don't know
so you're telling me this coffee is uh
this is this is your secret here no no I
don't know anything about this I'm
saying drinking coffee
four day minimal but I like how you
wouldn't co-sign on this immediately
until you tasted it yeah gotta taste it
so what's your favorite cigar
I like the kahibas do some Monte Cristo
like a robusto yeah robusto is good I
like the particus uh part I guess I've
been smoking for a long series D is
great yeah that's a smooth yeah they
hand those out at all at casinos for
years when you work Vegas whether you're
winning or losing they'll walk over and
give you a box of those what was that
like back then oh God when the mob ran
it was the best right bill look I came
down from Canada
used to hang around Massachusetts little
Hampton Beach Salisbury I mean that's
your hood right I won my first contest
in uh Salisbury Beach when I was like 15
years old I went to this little club and
I won a contest is that right yeah yeah
yeah yeah and actually now from Canada
because it was close we drive down my
dad would drive us down every summer so
I knew the whole area and then one of
the first places I played was blood
strips in Boston you might be too young
to remember I don't remember that one
yeah your parents would remember but
blinster was the place between the
Copacabana and blindstroms once you did
those two places the word got out to the
boys to the Mob then you got to Vegas oh
so if you had you if you were killing it
yeah I was killing it at the Copa as the
youngest one there I was like 19. in
fact I hired my first comic that I hired
was Jackie Mason
oh my God he was my opening act right
and I loved you I saw Jackie do a
one-man show yeah it was basically yeah
it was like brilliant two hours of
Comedy yeah
and or maybe even more than that like he
did like an hour and 15 took a 15 minute
break and came out and did another hour
yeah and like murdered and this was
another one where I went to go I saw him
in like 99 so I don't know how old he
was he was maybe pushing 70. I don't
know yeah so I went to go see him and
there was always that thing like I love
this guy I love this guy I love this guy
please please don't be sad don't be a
set and he came out Beast yeah we
murdered he's one of the guys that
stayed consistent you know in that world
and I've watched it for years guys make
their big hit guys that we probably love
and then it's a sliding slope from that
I mean look how you've kept it going
right but for every you you know what
that is that's fear-based because I see
those guys yeah you know what it is when
you start out when you're coming up you
see like you remember the first time you
opened for some guy you couldn't believe
you were like opening for and and they
were like
sliding down
and it was a combination of this thrill
of working with them and then the terror
of like oh that's what that looks like
like I thought this guy was just gonna
stay there and it's like no you don't
look at the guys look at Kennison who I
used to love look what happened to him
he was brilliant yeah no he's one of the
greatest ever I mean you know you look
at the list of guys that hit the slide
but but he was coming out of it that's
the worst part there's so many of those
guys that got sober
Kennison Stevie Ray Vaughan all of these
guys like they get sober and right is
there either just put out
like Stevie put out InStep and then he
did that great album uh family style
with Jimmy Vaughn and it was just all
like what is he gonna do in the 90s this
is going to be great and then it's just
it's over and like Kennison
like I don't think I ever saw a guy
like Fame just
I mean the difference between the [__]
yeah his first Letterman set I love that
his first Letterman set was like what's
this yeah and the vibe the vibe I saw in
that studio was like they always try to
build Comics up like this next guy's
wild like there was a legit like fear
like we don't know what this guy's gonna
do I don't think he even knew and it was
like
it was just one of those there was
before he did Letterman and then after
he did the marriage bit Yeah the crowd
yes it went right down to the front of
the aisle and he said wow yeah
and then but then the second one he did
you could see like his foot was off the
gas yeah and he was hey Dave what's up
Paul and that was the beginning of him I
mean it was also that one of the things
I felt made him so compelling was
he was so vulnerable and he was so like
blowing around or whatever but like I
think he learned a lot
and like from what I heard he had got
like sober and just the irony of getting
hit by a drunk driver yeah um but that's
also one of those guys I always think of
those guys like when someone will say
like man you're one of the best Comics
out there today blah blah I always think
well yeah because kennison's not around
Patrice O'Neal's not around Mitch
hedberg's not around Bernie Mac is gone
yeah like so many we lost so many Robert
schimel so many of these huge huge huge
like just like
these guys that we're going to have
a career like yours where you don't own
a new decade you're You're gone no I'm
gonna still go and I can adapt how how
were you able to do that by the way I
feel like music is way harder than
comedy you know when you when your kid
is 15.
and you write your own stuff
and all of a sudden you get lucky
and in 1516
here I am living the dream I'm working
the New York Paramount I'm up at Boston
I'm working with Chuck Berry Fats Domino
all the guys that were my Idols you make
a decision at that point you go man I
can't let this go
right you're sitting with Frankie Lyman
who's so talented but he's shooting up
heroin you know it he's giving you an
offer on it you're passing on it you're
making choices but it was tough because
what I found out early in the career was
every one of us that make it
we're not sophisticated you don't meet
sophisticated people they're given this
gift they're given this talent but off
the stage they go home they're with the
[__] bathrobe that you know they're
just down-home people yeah not
sophisticated trying to deal with the
success so you're going along this
journey and all of a sudden you get a
little wisdom how to deal with it when
it clicked in for me when I started
working for the mafia they controlled
the record business you know it was a
time of even when you went in to make a
record some kid would walk in with a hit
song and so one of the guys that I know
will be nameless will go well instead of
saying don't go over there and tell me
you love me come over here they put
their name on the song was called write
a word get a third so all these kids
were getting ripped off oh the mob would
do that well whoever was running around
so now when I get the call to go to
Vegas write a word get a third Jesus I'm
sitting there
Sinatra Rat Pack Sammy Davis and these
guys are twice my age maybe more
and you buy into it and you get it there
was nothing on the horizon that was it
Vegas and those guys and I said I gotta
get my [__] together and do what they do
me and Darren we talked about it because
the teenage thing wasn't going to last
and once we got into it and started
working it was unlike anything bill I
thought I'd ever experience yeah one of
the first times one of the first Teen
Idols
you and snookta were able to survive
that that Bobby and I survived it yeah
we went on to do the club thing Bobby
was amazingly talented so you guys as
teenagers were able to step outside that
and be like we need to have a plan for
our 20s yeah 30s that's amazing we
needed that Foundation if we were going
to continue the gravitas I had was I was
a writer you know nobody was really
writing you know Presley didn't write
and none of those kids wrote so I
started writing you know for Buddy Holly
that it had evolved and then Tonight
Show theme for Carson longest day I kept
that gravitas as the writer that's
unbelievable you wrote that song it's a
wild story with Johnny
[Music]
so I'm over in England I've got like
three records on the top 10 over there
but the English the English Bill some
people just go to England yeah I go to
England I got three records at the top I
would never have gotten through customs
so they invite me over there there's no
English Show Business
it's all us Chuck Berry Fats Domino
they're trying to emulate what Chuck
Berry was doing Buddy Holly Muddy Waters
so there's no entertainment business per
se in England so Granada TV called me
and said would you like to do a special
was that 19 years old 1920. he said sure
So we could sitting in meetings I said
you know what it's gonna be a little
boring with this teenage stuff let's get
some comic element because you know I've
always loved comedy right so they sent
me some kenniscopes and I start looking
at them and there's this one guy
he's drunk all night I mean he's
blasting it all night till like six in
the morning then he's got to go do a
show with kids
screaming kids five six seven eight
years old and Carson
would go and do this show for these kids
but he was absolutely hungover what was
the funniest thing I ever saw I said
that guy's funny
let's get him over here so Johnny comes
over get to know him I never professed
to say I knew him well not many people
could right but brilliant at what he did
does the show Fade Out fade in we go
back to New York I run into him on 57th
Street hey John how you been blah blah
blah what are you doing I think I'm
going to do this
tonight's show for a couple of years you
know I'm looking for again like Forrest
Gump stuff wow so I said I said great he
said you know and I might wanna we're
changing a few things I might want a
theme song well I'm the wrong guy to say
you know I never stopped with this about
music it was like the longest day there
was never going to be any music I tug
zanik into it anyway so I said hey John
let me do something so I agree and I
spent about 300 bucks and I do a demo
record for him and I send it
he calls me up he says I love it
and he calls me a couple of days later
he said
we can't use it because you know I'm new
in the show but this guy Skitch
Henderson who's the band leader doesn't
want any kid coming in here he's going
to do it he's been with the show for
ages and I'm new I said geez John plus
also the money if he comes up with the
theme song he gets paid every time
everything's about money to this day
anybody said it ain't [__] right so
it's Johnny look good I'm gonna give you
half the writers and I'm gonna give you
half the publishing you put your name on
it you're gonna have 50 of everything
I get a call the next day he says you
got it who knew it would be on all those
years he collected half the royalties on
that song for writers and for publishing
for as long as he was he was on the air
kaishu how did you how did you come up
with that stuff just come simple it's
just simple you know you know the
creative process you know you sit you're
alone
how you gonna get off you know what's
going to turn you on when do you arrive
at what you want you kind of Typecast
and I'd have the song I didn't know what
I was going to do with it but it fit
what I knew was going to happen for what
20 seconds it was just up it was Pepe
and it was sketchy it's like anything
you know that you sit there with you
know my way came to me at at midnight
storming outside New York City in my
apartment finished in five hours the
lyric why because I was motivated by
Sinatra who had told me he's quitting
Show Business
he's quitting Rat Pack was over had
dinner with him in Florida he said I'm
getting out he says you never wrote me a
song
I'm in my 20s I didn't dare take a
lonely boy or puppy love it would have
thrown me out the window I said we could
change the word to puppy level Called
Love is a [__] next
because I put him in that chair writing
and metaphorically it just wrote itself
same with Tom Jones once I got his
Swagger it's typecasting you know you
know it's like when you're sitting down
doing a routine okay I'm sick of
politics now where am I going to go now
with this where am I going to Clinton
okay I want to hit Hillary Obama's wife
and when you do the bit with Obama and
the Hillary Bill I just oh that [__]
fell diesel what is he doing well that
you know that one came about that came
about living in L.A yeah and everybody's
super liberal out here yeah so it was
like I knew that they that that would
bother them oh yeah you bothered them
alone I knew that that would bug them
but it's one of those things where uh
what's funny
so much of my stuff was just based on
going into room and thinking like what
do these people love yeah or don't love
and then I just kind of go I kind of go
against it so like what was fun during
the Obama Trump years yeah Biden's just
sat and nobody just wants you know but
like the the during those years what was
fun was in LA it was fun to trash Obama
like particularly This Club Largo right
well I don't know what it was but they
were just always extra sensitive
and I would just have some of the worst
sets of my life out here in La I would
have there but I would be having such a
good time but then I would go out to
like a red State and then I would I
would make fun of uh I would make fun of
trump so like
it was funny I would be in a red State
and they'd be like oh you liberal
Snowflake and blah blah blah and then I
would be out here in LA and then they
would think that I was like a Trumper
and it was like no I'm just I'm an
[__]
and there's always like for the most
part like what people look cool right
yeah and 99 of them can laugh
at what
you're doing if you're ripping them a
little bit but there's always that one
person that takes it seriously that's
the most fun person in the audience and
you're looking at them you kind of
glancing at them to see like you know
the temperature how mad you're making
them as you continue to do this stuff
and then every once in a while you're
glancing over at them and that becomes
the show within the show right right I'm
getting off I'm getting a laugh yeah and
you're actually with your negative
energy you're feeding me right to go
like even further like the amount of
times like I've had the guy laughing and
the woman is like looking at him and
stuff like
um
and sometimes I've apologized to the guy
I'll just or just like man this this is
me don't get mad at him don't make his
life miserable on the way home this is
like maybe yeah I've had I've had like a
lot of fun just sort of uh
just doing that and and like I feel like
with with comedy is
you know a big part of it too is you got
to make fun of yourself yeah and you
also have to kind of admit that you
don't know what you're talking about and
once you do that then the crowd can
settle in because um
during these times you know with social
media and stuff like that and
even everything got politicized even
like comedians I feel like
um
you know that style it's just not a fun
Style
to like no one wants to listen to
somebody that thinks they know
everything right or coming in saying
you're wrong or whatever like right
right and like so there's got to be a
way to do it where you can't say what
you think a little bit but you sort of
like but you are though joking around
but I'm also like
I am one of the things I'm proud about
of myself is that you can change my mind
like I've never be that guy look this is
the way it is yeah right and that's it
right right right I think I think the
way it should be but if you come to me
this happens a lot with my wife yeah
like I'll be like you know you did this
and because I'm emotionally walled off
when she explains the emotion of like
like last night we went to a fashion
show yeah at the Hollywood Bowl
obviously I'm not a fashion plate here
so I went there and she wanted to take a
picture you got your Vibe though huh
yeah I've watched you I just do what
you're wearing all the time what button
down in jeans I've been wearing the same
[__] if my if my if my comedy changed as
little as my wardrobe you wouldn't be
sitting here with me right now I
literally I literally not bought clothes
since before the pandemic right
um so
she wanted to get like a picture as we
were going in there yeah with the red
carpet no it was just walking up the
hill so you know I don't I'm sick of
taking pictures or whatever so I did the
whole thing all right you got it you got
it let's go let's go let's go and I saw
the sadness on her face and I was just
like oh I just did that thing again I
was like all right you're right you're
right this is something you wanted to go
to yeah you know if I took you to a
sporting event or something and you
tried to rush your way through it that
would bother you so I do have the
ability I'm not an [__] all the time
but when I'm on stage I am
the life routine
where yeah which one what do you mean
the tough job the toughest job when you
got into I'm sitting there going how's
he going to pull this off what do you
mean tough work leaning over I mean I
know all the routines I said this I
can't believe you know my stuff like
what do you mean are you kidding I don't
know I got grown women I got friends I'm
in the business you think I'm oblivious
just sitting there waiting for the next
my way well don't you ever feel like
what you're doing is just you in a
little room like I'm always surprised if
anybody knows who the hell I am oh they
know who you are when you're playing to
thousands of people you got your base
and I've got my core but you know what I
find though like I find like they know
who I am and the second the show's over
all I need to do is get three blocks
away from the from the theater and
nobody knows no he knows the same thing
yeah but I like that no I love it I like
that I don't want to be that guy that
like I can't go you know you see these
people my favorite celebrity thing ever
is the bowling alley in your house is
the funny you probably have one right
now no I don't okay good but like the
bowling alley in the house is like Jesus
Christ you can't go bowling right it's
like that like what kind of a it's like
with Elvis when we used to sit and talk
I could never get them at the dinner
okay can I just digest what you just
said it's like with Elvis when we used
to sit and talk can you please talk to
me about sitting and talking what year
what year was when I was at Caesar's
Palace uh when he started work in Vegas
the unicorn
but I knew him before because we were
with RCA Victor records you know there
was us this band of teenagers and then
there was Elvis this amazing looking guy
who had the its with a black voice and
we all looked at this guy right and
there was nobody like Elvis from our
menu of people I get to know him and
then I really get to know him in Vegas
when he started working Vegas when the
colonel signed him up at the Hilton and
I would go over and hang with them and
it was a hang you know you'd walk in a
room all the windows had aluminum foil
on it aluminum foil why
didn't want any daylight oh okay you
didn't know where people just go with
drapes not good enough not eccentric
enough yeah we're gonna get a drape out
of a drawer right and get the aluminum
foil so and they love the guns you know
he's shooting The Gunshot up the TV set
but the point that I was going to make
is wait you shot a gun in the hotel no
he didn't like Robert Goulet
and Robert Goulet came on television he
was a guy from Canada for some whatever
the hard-on he had for him and he came
on television he shot the TV he said I
said thank God for my way I'm gonna get
out of here alive right because he was
on my way what's that Jordan pick he
probably he probably took exception
somehow that the Robert Goulet let me
ask you you said something to see we
said he had like the black voice and
everything yeah did you ever talk to him
about how
um
the perception that people had like
like you know he was doing black music
and he was getting the credit and the
the black artists weren't and all of
that type of stuff which was a thing
because of the level of racism and all
of that but then like now like 70 years
later it's almost like they look at him
like he wasn't even talented where it's
like you got to be all right you got to
dial that this like there's a whole
bunch of like when I look at Elvis it's
like I understand all of that other
stuff but that um
he was sort of the blueprint I feel like
of the rock star where like every cliche
thing that a rock star can get involved
in like there was no information for him
where the hangers on people giving you
drugs like like literally everything you
know uh music changing somebody else
coming in and like and there was like
nobody I feel like he could really sit
down and talk to
like when you hit did you hit like he
came he he hit what 55 or 50 uses 55 I
hit in 56 and he hit about a year before
I did so when you were watching him like
and then he goes into the army and then
when he comes back the Beatles are out
right watching him navigating that yeah
and getting talked into doing the movies
and stuff and the Sinatra special and
all that yeah now were you and Bobby
Darin sitting there going like like
watching that going okay
I do this or I wouldn't do that
um or were you guys too close in age and
stuff was moving too fast for you to
contemplate that we were focusing on the
foundation we had and what we had to do
Elvis had his own Vibe we all knew that
we all knew the colonel couldn't leave
the country great Kearney guy he did you
know that back then that he couldn't
leave the country because yeah the word
was out you know everybody knew
everything you ever remember pop music
back then was in his infancy stage
there's no Hendrix yet there's no
Beatles yet right you know I I was
somewhat responsible for the Beatles
coming here because I was living over in
England I was living in France and I
would come home in a society that wasn't
media driven right you know people don't
fathom the fact that it wasn't a media
driven Society then you knew nothing if
CNN were around when Hitler was marching
you never left Germany you know today
it's like wow instant nobody knew what
was going on so the point was I would
come home from England I meet the
Beatles In Paris their work in the
Olympia Theater where I started as a kid
taking pictures with drinking we're
meeting hey Paul we want to publish and
we want to write and all of this stuff
and I'm coming home telling Normie Weiss
a general artist Sid Bernstein who are
my agents I said man there's these kids
they got the hair and they're doing
these covers and they're looking at me I
mean what beetles and I'm telling you I
love them you know I'm loved them as a
musician I said you've got to get over
there and sign them nobody knew they
were there
Fade Out fade in eventually they go over
in 64 and they bring the Beatles over
first shot on Ed Sullivan but till then
nobody knew they existed what were they
like what were they like when you were
hanging out with them did you I mean
there's no way you had any idea they
were going to be that big they were
different for me I'd never seen anything
like it but when you spoke with them and
you hung they still had that quirky
little Edge you know they always tried
to be like comedians they'd always have
something off points and make a little
humor out of it they were very much that
way but still you could see they were
trying to find their Niche because it
didn't happen you know in our business
until you put the mileage in you know we
know we all have to sweat it out you're
not there yet you know it took Elton 2
000 miles it took everybody some mileage
to get to where they're at same with
them they were just a cover band but
when you saw them
you knew there was something going on
and then the vibe started in Great
Britain the point I was making is till
them
Elvis was criticized my group criticized
anything indigenous to pop music the
fans loved us but the adults didn't like
us
most of us were widifying rock and roll
we were clergyman's answer because it
was all the black experience that I
loved and lived on I could barely get
them on the radio and you know I toured
down south I come out of Canada
and I'm touring down south and I got all
my black brothers who guys I idolize
Chuck Berry uh Lyman fats I don't know
I'm on a bus all of a sudden going
through the South where they're not
allowed in to eat
and I said [__] I ain't going in about
you guys now I'm a kid I'm starting to
compute this I said I ain't going in
I'll go get the food and bring it well
we can't go to the bathroom well let's
go five miles an hour you open the door
and you're pissing out outside of the
bus
I'd never seen anything like it White's
over here blacks over here cops dogs and
I'm with my brothers people that I
idolized as a kid couldn't do this you
couldn't do that boy what an Awakening
that was for me to see before the Civil
Rights
stay where you're at you think you know
everything that's going on and if you go
do the road you're like oh oh I didn't
know all of this stuff and then you end
up getting this great mindset of like
there's way more going on than I could
ever know and I don't really know
anything and I find the less
somebody uh has that experience the more
convinced they are
of like their beliefs
and uh and stuff like that because I
don't know I've really gotten to the
point of not saying I mean
I don't know anything
I mean I know how to do what it is that
I do but as far as like you know there
was a time where I thought that you know
you look at problems and you think you
could actually solve them and then you
get older you're just like it's just uh
I don't know how to uh doesn't work yeah
you know you could vote but you have no
power I woke up one day and said yeah
okay get it gonna vote but then you look
at and go I don't have any power you
know what I don't like I don't like how
you vote
for the people to go in there but then
like so much [__] that really affects
you you don't even get to vote on it
they vote on it they do and then they
got all these guys putting like money in
in their uh how these guys getting rich
did you ever look at the landscape of
those guys look don't ever bring the
Senate the multi-millionaires and they
make like freaking 200 Grand they don't
have any jobs to fall back on not one of
them when you look oh I used to be
better Thomas I used to be a lawyer no
jobs they get rich overnight and I've
looked at this for years the same game
and I'm convinced that there's this
hierarchy Club Vibe nah you're talking
my language here we go there we go watch
this happen and you see from a hundred
and ten thousand a Year everybody gets
Rich overnight what is that about yeah
you're you're somehow you make 110 Grand
a year and you're worth 20 million
what's going on I think I think all of
you know that that host speech tour
thing that the president 250 a shot
that's them washing their bribe money
because he did what they wanted them to
do it's so obvious to pay off it's so
obvious
it's a payoff it's the payoff whether
they have a red tie or a blue tie it's a
payoff that's why I feel in my lifetime
the only human being
that was president that really gave a
[__] about people was Jimmy Carter yes
and the proofs in the guy he just
recently because of Health has had to
slow down that guy's been building
houses for the homeless right into his
90s yeah everybody else regardless of
color a tie goes and gets the big house
does the speech tour and sort of
disappears Into The Ether onto like a
yacht and um
you know I might love thy country but
don't trust those that run it I never
thought I'd ever feel
that this was a corrupt country also
because I've been all over the world Man
Iron Curtain countries I've been to
every major what was that like you went
behind the Iron Curtain oh you won't
believe this story so I'm I'm in my
teenage days it'll be Elvis and The
Beatles I'm like go play Siberia I'm in
my I've been to Russia closest library
I'll tell you that story of Putin so I'm
sitting I'm over in Europe doing my
thing right some of my records kids
and I got to go to Geneva
frankly to visit my money
so I get on a plane and I go to Geneva I
do my business
and I go back to the airport you legit
had money out there
I'm not I take the fifth okay okay well
Obama went in and shut it all down so
it's a mute point so that's one of the
most gangster things I've ever heard so
I go to Geneva to visit my money it's a
long story
so I'm really I'm into the European
thing man right so I'm getting on the
plane and there are these guys with the
machine guns and the dogs
and you know in those days a year
60s 60s okay
and I'm getting on a plane
and I know there's a buzz
and they start bringing this group of
guys on and this one very
tall bald-headed strong-willed type guy
you could tell he was he was the boss
right when I get on a plane we're all
sitting around on the plane get ready
plane goes up we're sitting the first
class cabin
and he comes over to me he says I hear
your uh Paul Anka
yeah
and what 20s
says I'm president of Poland
and we love your music would you ever
come to my country
I would say no 30 000 people guys yeah
they go every weekend yeah my family
all my friends go for the weekend good
thanks so I said yeah I'd love to fade
up faded I get home
but a month later my manager calls he
says did you meet the president of
Poland I said yeah I was on a plan
he said you tell me you wanted to go to
Poland I said no yeah he says when he
got in touch with the government and
this fifteen thousand dollars in the
Bank of America and they want you to go
is it really he says they think it's a
good idea it's okay so I round up the
boys
we fly to Poland
now you lose sight of what you got in
your own country but when you land in a
place like
Poland yeah
depressing great people but depressing
you check in your hotel
dark
one bathroom at the end of the hall no
other bathrooms you go to work and you
see people lined up to these stores to
get toothpaste to get clothing it was
the most depressing trip
but
I'm saying to myself I'm going to play
to 15 000 people tonight how
and we drive out to the stadium
and from my window I could see these
streetcars
coming all the way down the street with
thousands of people in them into the
side of the stadium empty them out and
leave again
and say this is ridiculous
so anyway I do the show
we finished the show how is the crowd
amazing they knew all the music and
here's how
I'm leaving and they're all come up to
me with these little postcards
like a postcard made of wax they got
grooves in them
and music with a hole in it
I said what is that they said Cuba
bootlegs All-American music and sends
them over here and that's how we hear
you because you couldn't sell records
over in those countries so they knew me
through these postcards right
I had the greatest time with those
people but here's the kicker
my last night in Warsaw in a beautiful
Concert Hall I mean aesthetically well
appointed everything acoustically the
Russians had built it and given it to
the polls
I'm sitting in my dressing room with the
head of UPI United press and we're
talking
just before the show
in the corner of the room there's this
radio old radio and radio free Europe
would be always broadcasting with the
limited vocabulary to all the communist
countries however they can infiltrate
and I'm looking at the guy
and I hear from the radio
and the president arrived in Dallas at
one of the motorcade went you know when
you're sitting somewhere in your hearing
but you don't believe in your [__]
hearing and I stopped they said hey Tom
wait
he was shot at it and I'm hearing
the whole Kennedy story you were in
Poland I'm in Poland remote another
country
and you feel it you start crying yeah I
go on stage I said ladies and gentlemen
my president has just been shot
it was like Bedlam in there all the
front rows were government people
they're getting up they're running out I
said
I can't finish the show can't finish the
tour I'm going home but I'll come back
one day packed up
went to the airport the next morning
people were coming up with matchbook
covers we loved him we loved the U.S
it's the Russians
shut down the tour
a couple years ago I went back 50 years
later and I finished that concert oh my
God in a new country you should see what
it looks like now you've been I've been
there because it didn't uh like the
Poland you saw was not the poem I saw
Paul and I saw they were fun oh they
were amazing modernized yeah I think we
I think I went to Warsaw they had like a
great someone was telling me along their
Coast they have this these great beach
towns unbelievable yeah I stayed there
oh you did stay oh yeah that was
someplace uh I'll give you the name of
the place in a second because I didn't
show there
yeah
I rented this crazy chick one time in
Iceland before you were married no I was
married you go to you went to Iceland I
went to Iceland and I was sitting on
this
way to God yeah I was sitting on a
grassy no I'm gonna bring it back to
Kennedy right I'm up on this and I'm
smoking this cigar by myself yeah this
blonde chick walks up to me and she has
like this accent she goes hey how are
you doing whatever I'm like hey what's
going on she definitely had weird vibes
I'm kind of sitting there going like and
I was literally like looking down like
all these people walking over there and
I'm clearly up here kind of stating that
I kind of wanted some alone time so of
course she comes up to me she goes this
is a weird
uh question to ask but can you
roll me down the hill
just grassy Hill and I'm going give me
some rolls I totally forgot this story
you ever told us on the podcast but I
was like what
she goes I wanna I've never been to
Iceland this beautiful grassy thing it's
like a little kid thing she wanted to do
that is and I'm sitting there going like
I don't know how many times did you roll
her just one I know right I just I gave
her a little and she did she went like I
think she said we which may be even
scarier right better even scarier and
then uh we had like an awkward
afterwards I was laughing but also like
freaked out like this is right I thought
she was a witch for half a second and
then
um but she gave great room no but yeah
she said that she end Up's going like
I'm from Poland I said oh you know I I
did a show over there and then that's
what she told me about the coast and I
was just kind of like all right see you
later I totally forgot about that this
is a cool place yeah I went up there I
didn't get to see the Northern Lights
but I went up there and um me and my
wife and my daughter I got a son now too
but my daughter we went and uh did like
a whale watch and like you just see him
they just go out there and they were
jumping all over the place and uh I've
had a
you know I've had a a great time
going over there but
um
I got to tell you before um
because I want to go smoke a cigar with
you now if we can whatever time yeah
whatever I gotta tell you like
um
that show I saw you doing Wilshire I'm
never gonna forget that show what you
know I have to what were you doing there
why I was there because we we put the
song in the in the movie
they tell you that you told me about I
don't know that you do you do I eye the
tiger I shot this movie uh called Old
dads it's about guys my age that have
kids right late in life and then like a
17 year old exactly so I go to like you
know my daughter's in kindergarten I was
in kindergarten 50 years ago right so
everything has changed right over there
yeah every five seconds put my foot in
my mouth I feel saying something stupid
right so that's basically a comedy so
one point they're good they're all going
to go to Vegas right and we needed some
vacancy type music but that's Sinatra
thing had been done to death yeah and
then my editor
said to me he goes hey man you know Paul
ankle did this you know rock swings or
whatever and it was perfect because it
was my generation's music with the Rat
Pack sound right it works so perfectly
and we ended up choosing Eye of the
Tiger right so then I was just and I
started you know going golfing with my
friends and I would put that album on
and everybody loved it I was just like
you know what man I'm gonna I'm gonna
see this guy I gotta see this guy is a
and I started all of this stuff this guy
wears a Tonight Show Theme I didn't know
that put your head on my shoulder oh my
God right so I'm like I gotta go see
that guy so a buddy I work with um
Mike bertolino he's into all of that
stuff so I go we don't see him I go
we're gonna put suits on right this
guy's a class guy you know and uh you
know the guys wear shirts and all of
that
you're 100 right right and you were 100
right Howard Stern loves it once he
endorsed it I said okay I'm in you were
100 right you go out there and dress
like a bunch of bumps you know you
represented me put a [__] shirt on
that's right so uh yeah first time I I
went into that rant like one time I was
like yeah what's the problem this guy is
100 right so uh
yeah we like we're gonna go around I
would put me right on that I have did it
a couple of times oh yeah and he just
loved it I mean he was on like you are
absolutely ripsing out thank God I guess
guys get sure what I was was the way you
were saying I could tell you would set
it a thousand times before yeah you were
beside yourself the [__] guys get
shirts right right so a little more than
that they're [__] up musically too
yeah but you know all of those that's
like uh the the classic Buddy Rich one I
get you out there when I gotta get
[__] clams it's like people just
think it's funny because they're hearing
somebody famous flipping out but it's
like what I hear is a guy that cares
about his audience right and it's like
and it's like guys this thing that we
have is precious and it can all go away
absolutely if we start going out there
dressing like bombs and not giving a
[__] about what we're playing that's
right and I've worked too goddamn hard
to have some [__] punk half my
goddamn Age come walking out there
dressed like some [__] hippie yeah
playing [__] clams that's just as
strong as your weakest link right
exactly oh yeah this is for you
this is a gift to you
let me read that when you get home okay
good because I'll probably get emotional
because you take this it's yours what
yes
oh my God I want you to have that I feel
like I'm on a prank show where you're
then gonna be like I'm just kidding I
have no idea who the [__] you are and
this doesn't even work
obviously post I heard you were there
and I'm going
bill was in my audience nobody [__]
told me I know you must have just got
tickets from the rabbi you know the
rabbi runs the place oh no I said I
can't see him going to the rabbi no I
went on StubHub
I went on StubHub we played right
through the nose we sat we had we sit in
lower level Center house so you came
down the right aisle that's right and
you came right by us too and you would
just yeah beaming The Joy on your face
yeah and then it was just contagious it
was over and I I feel like that thing
that you do you you two three times you
came into the country
right yes but opposite energy you're
right we're leaving for Asia in a couple
of weeks doing an old Asian tour where
are you coming open Singapore
I've done Singapore where'd you work
down there in the theater
um the big theater where did I work I
figured Sands Hotel
no I did play a theater
I did this great thing about I did
Australia all the way out to Perth yeah
the whole place I love this and then I
did New Zealand yeah and then I'm like
oh Singapore's right there not realizing
it was still like a 10 hour flight right
North went all the way up there
only stayed there for like a day and a
half then I did Hong Kong then I did
Mumbai India I'm doing Hong Kong I'm
doing Bangkok I'm doing Tokyo oh my god
well you know what I love about going
over the one time that I actually went
to Asia was
the experience that that is all
happening on the same planet that I live
on because it felt like an alternate it
literally felt like I went to another
planet because you go over there that's
right and they have everything we have
here but different it's like they have
they have their United and American
Airlines but it's not called that they
have their pop stars they have their TV
shows and I love putting on the TV show
and seeing a show kind of like ours and
it's like did they take this from us so
we'd steal it from them that's about
Korea yeah like we because we I know a
couple guys you know have taken
blueprints
yes but I went over there and um
the food the people and all that
homogeneous yeah it was homogenous
Society yeah we're not and I've been
going there since I was 17 years old
and when you go see that productivity
and the way they're culturally driven
you take a country like Japan
everyone doesn't realize what an amazing
country they are in terms of how they
look after their elderly their Workforce
their demographic how they know exactly
where they fit in that room I wish I
wish this country like old people and
Veterans I wish that they're not big
enough they're not looking after them
Japan looks after their people you know
when they made that Accord up in New
Hampshire when the American government
sat down with all those countries and
said okay
we're going to get rid of all this war
[__] we're going to change
everything we control all the shipping
lanes
take your money now you don't need it
for Armament start putting it back into
your people we're going to protect you
that was the emergence of globalization
and all those countries that started to
rise and be very affluent Etc when it
started in that meeting that they had up
in New Hampshire and you see all those
countries now who's affluent who is are
you at that meeting I missed it I was
busy I missed by date
I said you were at that one too
um you want to go smoke a cigar yeah oh
my God
[Music]